welcome to this video playing men of
light from Belgium yeah you see I have
taken a you to rating hit yeah since the
last uploaded game and this is really a
bit funny the first first game I played
and I had a pretty good position I liked
it a lot good end game and then I lost
by disconnection which very rarely
happens I have a pretty stable internet
connection and yeah was this was very
annoying of course and then I played the
next game and this was really really
funny I had a good position I had
spoiled and I was not laughing really
hard against the very low rated player
1800 and then instead of stop recording
I hit a hit delete there is there are
three buttons here my recording software
delete pause and stop and you hit stop
if you just put an end to the recording
I just accidentally hit delete so this
game is gone it was it was quite
interesting actually I mean I was I
wasn't very enthusiastic about losing
against some 1800 player but it was an
interesting game and I just accidentally
deleted it so if you need to live with
that some people might might might come
up and say yeah you don't upload your
losses blah blah blah
yeah I'd really accidentally hit the
delete button it it sometimes sometimes
happens okay we have a wretched opening
here interesting interesting form of it
hmm I don't want him to play d4 really
d4 you 495 don't know yeah but I cannot
really allow him to play d4
maybe 92 was a possibility
I don't know okay well this this makes
things easy I was more concerned that he
might might try to play the night
somewhere else and play up six okay
mmm-hmm
should be three or just I think just
capturing this is probably fine now put
this on a three to get c5 put it on c5
now I can try to build up the on the C
file behind behind this Bishop 22 or
maybe a four immediately attacking his
pawn structure how many takes look each
way seven okay this I didn't expect
sorry
got some boys problems and this actually
accidential deletion sometimes happens I
think there's also some some setting
that that that the software actually
asks you do you really want to delete
this thing and but I have to switched
off it seems okay
we should have one
it's the Lydian okay so let's see now
Bishop everyone or should I just just
capture and not sure I want to be sure
Piazza for defensive purposes Roxy to
was the idea yeah he wants to play g5 I
think g5 and for those kind of things
mmm how do i i like how can i play play
forcefully here look a seven would be
nice get this this look on the seventh
know maybe this quincy one group system
one thing g5 fYI OSF Bishop h3 or queen
g4 okay this is a nice if he abandons
the idea of any counter play didn't
really look at the clock bunch down on
the clock just not nothing out of the
ordinary but I didn't really recognize
that before
[Music]
Bishop f1 and we each form contingent
well this is not so very nice both both
both captures are great of course
[Music]
yeah I should play play h4 as well just
to keep everything protected I protected
is wrong but everything in order so that
g5 I can take let's see how do i how do
i oh queen trade ok check let's get the
King King involved
[Music]
I thought he would go to e-file actually
he didn't do that the positive thing
about all this is very easy to play now
and with total control I'll be five
coming the bishop end game is very very
nice easily one cheque just pick up pick
up the pieces him check-check black
resigns I never got any any big counter
play going here the structure some is
quite convenient for white in any case
but he should try to get something going
here yeah that's an interesting counter
play idea but the computer before me
before I said it's quite strong actually
he wants to get in where it wants to get
in the Queen here maybe also a5 Bishop
a6 get rid of this bad bishop and this
is a tactical justification assess is
equal by the comp I'd still say what
should be somewhat better isn't this
isn't is somewhat better maybe black is
active enough I thought that maybe this
is a slightly problematic pawn this is
not a good Bishop well this can be
activated but ok blame black probably
has another activity in the game week
really rather quickly go to a situation
what
[Music]
okay
at first the stock fish shed this is
totally equal which is quite strange
white white is quite clearly better here
I mean this is must be phrased right
it's clear that only white can be
somewhat better
how much is not not so clear but it's
definitely not equal okay well but about
here it starts to get ugly for black
here it just has a bad structure bad
bishop only 786 a week he can never
really take on c5 that's just just a
terrible position I always kept some of
the advantage which I think he
definitely should try some some sort of
counter play here this is also not not
totally clear I mean I I made an effort
to put the rooks here to have some
protection but it's not not clear desist
of him here black definitely has some
counter play yeah well this is this is
now very one-sided of course you can
improve but after this wide Windsor
definitely this is like giving it up why
doesn't Otakon showing off with a passer
a six week check this is very very
one-sided wide wins wins this rather
he's in the I guess especially
considering the bad pawn structure in
relation to the bishop so even rook
traits are winning so it's quite quite
nice now okay thanks for watching